probably is not a good move yeah now
he's also getting closer to to millions
of checks with Queen F6
or queen ha Checkmate is a threat
he's a threat
oh my God
yeah that's true I mean it looks like
black is super safe and he's trying
everything for risk-free but
all these checks yeah Queen visa and
then look at this yeah also hiko doesn't
he's also not so happy yeah no he's down
to 13 seconds himself
King G4
Queen G7 check Queen G7 yeah six and
King back to F3 yeah
Queen C8 by Hikaru wow
King FC Queen CC wow yes now he's just
enjoying it
but why not Queen F6 check that was
surprising
okay now apparently Magnus has 15
seconds and he is giving a Perpetual
check
King G8 Queen G6 check
and Hikaru shaking his head yeah he
doesn't look so happy huh yeah of course
will Magnus
yeah there is nothing here
yeah King G8
will we see the repetition
for the first time in the game up on the
clock yeah yeah
yeah that's it handshake wow
I'm completely exhausted incredible
drama yeah yes well I mean now Magnus is
really relieved to have survived this
care
yeah
wow with one minute on the clock and
then with 10 seconds on the clock to
make so many moves
super tough
super tough super super tough wow gives
us the chance to look around you have